tough times in Georgia to where
hospitals there are quickly nearing
capacity Atlanta maraquita Lance bottoms
just issued an executive order requiring
face masks in public spaces
earlier this week she revealed that she
tested positive for COBIT 19 but she
also says she has no symptoms she joins
us from her home in Atlanta where she is
quarantine e good morning to you mayor
bottoms it's very good to see you this
morning
we should say this when you announce
your diagnosis that got a lot of
attention good morning got a lot of
attention first because of course you're
the mayor second you had no symptoms and
you said that you and your family had
been so vigilant and so diligent about
following the rules it affected your
husband one of your children your other
two were getting tested how did that
turn out for them well actually the
other three were tested and thankfully
they are all negative Gayle but like so
many people across America
we had an asymptomatic child in our
house and we didn't know it and had we
received our earlier test results back
sooner test result today that only took
because I had attended a funeral and
just decided to get the entire family
tested had we received those sooner we
would have known that we had an
asymptomatic child in the house but by
the time we were tested again then three
of us had tested positive and that's the
story that's happening across this
country in this the reason we can't get
to the other side of this crisis yes
it's been reported mayor that you had
delays in getting your results which is
scary to me because you're the Mary you
would think if anybody would get this I
don't want to say special treatment but
if anybody who could get their results
back quickly it would have been you what
does that say about testing in your
state that our testing system is failing
it took me eight days to get our test
results back and again at that point one
person in the house is positive and this
is the reason this virus is continuing
to spread this is the reason that people
are inadvertently putting people in
harm's way and it is extremely
frustrating it's disappointing there's
so many countries across the globe who
somehow been able to perfect testing and
contact tracing
yet again we are still failing in this
country and specifically in the state of
Georgia well all of the checks all of
the top experts as we know say everybody
please wear your mask I've even heard
people say wear your damn mask for
emphasis and so you've issued an
executive order in Atlanta saying in our
in our city you're going to wear your
mask your governor on the other hand has
said that's not enforceable he doesn't
seem to be supporting you on this how
are you navigating that in the
relationship between the two of you well
you know this is the same governor who
thought that it was a good idea for us
for our state to open up with business
as usual when we were not trending
downward with our Kovach number so right
now we have hospitals that are reaching
capacity our major trauma center Grady
Hospital is seeing more Kovach patients
and saw in April and so I have to do
what I am charged to do and that is to
make the best decisions on behalf of the
people of Atlanta and so we're pushing
forward in other mayor's across the
state have done the same thing
mayor Johnson and Savannah did it I
believe mayor Davis and Augusta and so
this is happening throughout the state
so the governor really seems to be the
only elected official one of the few in
this state who doesn't think that
mandating masks are a good idea you know
president Trump is heading your way
heading to Atlanta next week do you plan
to meet with him and if so what what is
your message to him what do you want him
to know about your city well I doubt
that he wants to meet with me and the
feeling is mutual
but what I want president Truong to do
is lead it is just that simple he is
making an already bad situation worse we
are seeing challenges throughout our
cities including challenges with testing
if he would allow the experts to do
their job then I think that lives could
be saved across this country but he's
silencing the scientists he's silencing
dr. Falchi
he's interfering with guidelines coming
out of the CDC and it's costing people's
lives we just simply want him to allow
us to live give us an opportunity to
receive the most unbiased scientific
information on Kovan and he continues to
interfere with that
you know mayor bottoms you were sworn in
as mayor in 2018 but you you you gained
a lot of national attention earlier this
year because you gave such an
impassioned plea to your city the first
week of the protesters I remember so
clearly were you saying approach us you
need a plan you said your 18 year old
son was out you called him and said
where are you your pain and your love
and your strength for the city was so
palpable to me and many people who are
watching you so I'm wondering how you're
navigating this you you have mamabear
tendencies that come out you were very
upset when a young girl was killed in
your city recently so I'm wondering how
you're navigating you're a mayor you're
a mother of four you're a wife you're
your husband also was affected by covet
very great he was affected greatly how
are you navigating all of these roles go
I take it one day at a time and there's
some days as of late that I simply take
it one hour at a time and just make the
best decisions that I can possibly make
and part of that means that I have to
speak my truth and my truth is that I do
have concerns as a mother specifically I
have four children three of whom are
african-american boys so I understand
the frustration the fears and even anger
that so many people are feeling but I
also have this responsibility to lead
our city and this is a very challenging
time for our city and we're seeing it
happen across the country but I think
there are two things we have to do one
we've got to deal with the immediate
issues that are before us and then we
have to continue to fight and push to
address these systemic issues that are
causing disparities in health care and
causing people to go into the streets
and express their anger in a balanced
way Mary you're also it's been widely
reported and well-known that your
you appear to be on Joe Biden short list
for a vice presidential candidate and
you were asked recently are you ready
and you said yes
unequivocally you did not stutter you
did not stammer you did not hesitate
what makes you so confident I realize
you're not courting the position I get
it you already have a big job but what
makes you so confident that you'd be a
good candidate for him Oh Gail there
there's a saying if you stay ready you
don't have to get ready and as mayor you
have to stay ready because you are faced
with any number of challenges every day
I've served in three branches of
government I've served as a judge I've
served as a legislator and now as an
executive as mayor and the challenges
that we face and deal with in Atlanta
every day really represent the
challenges that are happening across
this country especially in this moment
in time and so I I'm a leader and I
believe that when you were searching for
a vice presidential candidate you need
someone who's able to lead in a crisis
that being said and what Joe Biden put
on that ticket whoever it is he thinks
will help him beat Donald Trump in
November because we cannot take four
additional years of what we dealt with
in this country
all right maracuja Lance bottoms I hope
you look I hope you feel as good as you
look we're sorry about the diagnosis but
do you feel okay right now I do just
allergy symptoms I actually slept for a
very long time yesterday which is
unusual but I'm doing well thank you for
asking I admire that you can sleep I'm a
little jealous about that but thank you
very much I know you got a lot on your
plate thank you for taking the time